Trump said quote why do Republican  Senators allow a broken down hack  politician Mitch McConnell to openly  disparage hard-working Republican  candidates for the United States Senate  this is such an affront to honor and to  leadership he should spend more time and  money helping them get elected and less  time helping his crazy wife and family  get rich on China so I believe that what  Donald Trump is doing here is setting  the groundwork in place to have  something else to blame the 2022 midterm  defeats on in the event that his  candidates lose their respective races  and he really just has so many built-in  excuses at this point like if an  anti-trumper or a half-trump supporting  candidate loses their race well he can  just jump in and say that's because they  were against me they were not a true  pro-trump candidate and that's exactly  why they lost